hi ho there Kermit the Frog here and
today I'm going undercover on the
internet with my friends at GQ to find
out what my fans want to know it's
actually me
[Music]
or am I active on social media oh sure
yeah you can follow me on Facebook
Twitter Instagram but I'm also on Insta
swamp and face bog but mostly to stay in
touch with family you know I try not to
let social media take over too much of
my life you know what I mean a little
warm is the last time that I posted uh
or I I can't remember exactly
um you know it was either my President's
Day photo of Abraham Lincoln's pet
bullfrog Cecil or my contractually
obligated Valentine's Day post about
Miss Piggy uh either way you just have
to follow me to find out first up
Instagram
at world's biggest Kermit fan commented
this Frog's got drip on this photo of me
oh that's nice let's see here
um thanks for noticing world's biggest
Kermit fan we frogs Prine ourselves on
our drip you see frogs have active
secretion glands that drip mucus and
help keep us safe from predators and
breathe underwater so I definitely have
drip lots of helpful mucousy drip e well
drip means style and Flair really yeah
gee I wonder if all frogs know that oh
well you know what this is a great
reminder why the backspace button is so
useful well just we'll just do that and
we'll do this
thank you for the nice compliment
next we have a comment on Instagram from
at all hail ice cream who says is this
really Kermit the Frog and uh would you
look at that what a blast from the past
let's see here um yes at all hail ice
cream that is indeed me you might not
have recognized me without my collar and
as you can see back then it wasn't
really easy being green because I was
more of a chartreuse there we go
over to Twitter
this one's from
oh
aunt Miss Piggy and you really pulled
some tough questions here Miss Piggy
posted uh dear Aunt Kermit the Frog
please ditch the jester collar look and
try out something more in Vogue wearing
the same thing every day is such a
fashion ballpark good grief
you know what I think my collar is nice
but if there is one thing that I have
learned about Miss Piggy it is that
flattery is the sincerest form of um
got flattery so uh let's see here I
appreciate the fashion tip from someone
as stylish as you as you once told me a
classic never goes out of style she'll
love that
next up from at bobbykey89 who asks did
at Kermit the Frog ever
um looks like Miss Piggy replied she
says oh kermi I didn't know you were
online
voo absolutely must join Moi for a live
stream well uh yeah I would but you know
I'm right in the middle of this actually
me
segments let's see here uh thanks for
the invite I'm doing an actually knee
segment for GQ right now so I'm a little
swamped enjoy your live stream
now where were we okay
um that's right at Bobby key 89 wanted
to know
what now uh oh great it's at Statler
Waldorf they ask uh is that the series
where you have to respond to ridiculous
questions from the internet uh is this
how these things normally go
no okay let's see if so we have a
question for GQ and you know I'm sorry
that this is kind of going off the rails
here
they say uh why doesn't GQ get someone
exciting like that Mr Bretton Goldstein
for the show instead of you frog good
grief I mean Brett Goldstein already did
the show these guys are really behind
the times you know weren't more I I I
can't believe this I'm so sorry uh oh
this is from Gonzo he asks uh Kermit
while you're with GQ ask them if they
got my
37 emails about doing a profile on the
fashion of the modern weirdo
actually that could be a compelling read
okay now there's a tweet from scooter
and uh it says here uh chief he calls me
chief did you see my text about game
night I need your RSVP ASAP so I know
how much pizza to order oh that actually
sounds kind of fun let's see uh I will
be there my pizza order is
hang on Rizzo replied before I could oh
now there's Fozzie look I'm sorry I I
can't keep up with all of this uh maybe
I better try to put a stop to it here we
go let's see um I'm still in this GQ
thing can everybody please stop replying
until I'm done
foreign
probably should have seen that coming
all right you know what let's try to get
back to at Bobby key 89's question
before anybody else
[Music]
and uh yep there it is that's Pepe right
on cue he says uh you're with GQ tell
them I'm available for next month's
cover or any month after through 2027.
yeah this is gonna stop
well you know let's see here like I said
I am busy right now so please please
stop replying until I am finished
ah
there that should do it
okay yeah so uh the Electric Mayhem says
we can get oh nope it's gone now Miss
Piggy is back and she says uh but when
will now it's gone to what does GQ stand
for hilarious Fozzie there's Uncle
deadly and Rizzo and Gonzo and
I guess the Muppets have finally broken
the internet
uh
and your computer sorry about that
yeah whoa
you know uh
I set aside a little me time for
self-care because a moment's uh just
like this
so I guess we're going to stop here
thanks to GQ for having me and uh my
apologies to at bobbykey89 someday we'll
answer that question this is Kermit the
Frog signing off from the internet for a
while uh maybe forever
yeah well this didn't happen when Chris
Hemsworth did the show